this Ryan Reynolds movie died in early
death when it hit theaters verse after
years spent lying in a cinematic grave
it's getting resurrected for a second
shot at the Big Time on Netflix
well Ryan Reynolds are starting some
well-received movies like Deadpool free
guy and waiting his career includes a
few box office misfires as well
nevertheless his career seems relatively
unshakable with years and years as a
leading man after appearing in several
television series and TV movies early on
Reynolds got his first big break with
National Lampoon's Van Wilder in which
he plays a fast-talking Scamp that
doesn't play by the rules sounds
familiar no I think Ryan Reynolds got
this far on his Superior acting method
possible pigeonholing aside Reynolds is
certainly popular these days bolstered
by his excitement around playing
Marvel's Mark with a mouth his constant
back and forth on social media with his
famous wife Blake Lively and his cell
phone service company mint mobile
Reynolds is a star outside of major
franchise releases too including an
Apple TV plus is Spirited a Reynolds and
Will Ferrell Christmas time team up now
it seems that Reynolds present-day
popularity is breathing life into one of
his older films and one that certainly
qualified as a flop when it was
originally released currently Ryan
Reynolds RIPD is apparently attracting
the attention of a considerable number
of viewers online Landing yet at the top
of Netflix's top 10 list RIPD originally
premiered in theaters back in 2013 and
stars Reynolds and Jeff Bridges are
Supernatural cops remind you of anything
do you mean
well it's a ship ship I didn't see a
departure plans for today
r.i.pd's Light twist and a well-worn
genre Trope is that the cops are both
dead and now exist as Phantoms in the
world of the living their jobs as Undead
specters see them tasked with hunting
down other dead people who remain at
large attempting to duck the afterlife
this means that Reynolds and bridges
characters can manifest in the physical
world in different bodies but for the
caveat that they cannot reveal their
true nature to civilians of course this
becomes a source of Comedy throughout
the film I'm not a piece of meat put on
this Earth for your gratification I'm a
woman respect me or I'll castrate you
like a three-year-old steer
however it seems like the critics
weren't laughing despite an All-Star
cast comprised of cinematic powerhouses
like Reynolds Bridges Kevin Bacon and
Mary Louise Parker critics weren't kind
to the film and reviews published around
the time of its release likewise the
movie didn't perform well at the box
office earning 79 million dollars
against the 130 million dollar budget
Beyond Reynolds growing presence and the
present-day pop cultural Zeitgeist the
resurrection of RIPD as a hit on Netflix
seems to simply be the result of the
film joining the streaming services
catalog at the start of March 2023
nevertheless its sudden and sharp rise
in popularity is all the more surprising
When taking into account where critics
had to say about the film in
contemporaneous reviews for example
Roger ebert.com writer Stephen Boone
awarded RIPD one star and concluded his
review by stating quote it's an awful
awful film
this is a joke meanwhile for the
guardian Mark kermode rated the film two
out of 5 stars and criticized as lack of
a proper reason to exist overall it's a
directionless mess too expensive for a b
movie two grown up for a kids movie
funeral's bereavement and jokes about
Steely Dan and too infantile for
everyone else no wonder it died on its
feet in the U.S that said its addition
to Netflix's at least unsurprising near
the end of 2022 a prequel with none of
the original cast returning titled ripd2
rise of the Damned became available to
Netflix subscribers of course for
Reynolds fan base quality or the
existence of a sequel may even be beside
the point rather easy access to a new
Reynolds film seems to have been enough
of a reason to make what was once a
major theatrical flop into a streaming
success
[Music]